les 400 tracteurs d'un agriculteur
collectionneur ce soir vous allez nous
parler de nouvelles ventes aux enchères
pour le moins étonnante en Loir-et-Cher
et cette fois les stars ce sont des
camions 70 au total certains centenaires
une collection exceptionnelle à masser
par un homme Jacques Passenaud décédé
l'an dernier et qui en avait fait un
musée ils seront proposés au plus
offrant ces tracteur c'est camion Pardo
justement ce samedi dans le regard
familial de Cormenon au nord de Vendôme
ouais ce reportage d'Alien chapelet
le nez de requin c'est la terreur des
routes elle est montée
les amis
vilaine de 1958 en entrevoit
l'impressionnante diversité du musée
passnot un héritage que Catherine et
Denis refuse que l'on qualifie de
cadeaux empoisonnés eux évoque un trésor
imposant pendant 30 ans dans cette
ancienne tannerie leur père à
collectionner et réparer des véhicules
anciens majoritairement des camions le
plus vieux d'entre eux et ce poids lourd
suisse de 1911 de la marque sorer il se
démarre à la manivelle et consomme près
de 50 litres au 100 km
les clignotants gauche étant donné que
le volant est à droite bah ça
fonctionnait avec un petit système de
ficelle comme ça donc il suffisait de
tirer sur la ficelle pour mettre le
clignotant de l'autre côté c'était plus
simple on mettait le bras les pneus
c'était des pneus à bandage donc c'est
du caoutchouc mais solide il y a pas
d'air de donc l'avantage c'est qu'on
crevait pas le gros inconvénient c'était
le confort près de 70 véhicules vont
être mises aux enchères le samedi 30
septembre une collection exceptionnelle
que le grand public peut venir découvrir
sur place ces jeudis et vendredis un
rendez-vous qui devrait ravir les
passionnés de vieilles mécanique tout
comme l'était le fondateur de ce musée
du poil lourd il descendait à son musée
à 8h30 9h il était là
montait déjeuné il revenait à 14h et
voilà c'était sa passion c'était sa vie
ici tout est à vendre des véhicules bien
sûr mais aussi des moteurs ainsi qu'une
large gamme d'accessoires avec des mises
à prix accessibles à tous
les enchères vont de 30 euros c'est pour
une petite pompe à huile jusqu'à 10
15000 euros pour les camions les plus
rares il y a certains camions qui sont
connus qu'à un ou deux exemplaires sur
terre donc j'espère qu'il y aura un peu
de bagarres et que le marteau retombera
pour cela direction donc le nord-ouest
du Loir-et-Cher à Cormenon pour
découvrir de visu cette collection
unique en France